[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Welcome to "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
I'm Max Saltonstall.
And lately, I've been
thinking, security
is a constant challenge in the
Cloud and never fully solved.
Most companies
work with a variety
of vendors, and
platforms, and solutions
to keep their people
as safe as possible.
Today, I'm pleased to welcome
Mason, from Palo Alto Networks,
to talk a little bit about
how their solutions work well
with Google security products.
Hi, Mason.
Welcome.
Can you tell me a
little bit about who
you are, what your role is, and
what you're doing right now?
MASON YAN: Thank you, Max.
My name is Mason Yan.
I'm with Palo Alto Networks
for about three years.
I lead the Google Cloud
Alliance Technical Team.
My team has been building
better together solution
with Google Cloud.
We help customer use Palo Alto
Networks and the Google Cloud
together.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's awesome.
And Palo Alto
Networks and Google
both have a lot of
different security products.
So Palo Alto Networks
can help in many ways
and can integrate
with Google, right?
MASON YAN: Yeah, that's correct.
So we promote a cybersecurity
platform approach.
We cover across the [? cost ?]
security, network security,
[? start ?] the access--
secure access service edge,
which allow all users access
from anywhere security.
We also cover endpoint security
and security operations.
The benefit of the
platform approach
is to allow customer use
consistent security policies,
eliminate gaps.
Of course, you know the scale
issue has been challenging
in the security industry.
You can never hire enough
security professionals, right?
We try to do automation
as much as possible.
We try to help customer
solve 95% of their alerts
automatically, so the customer
can really focus on the 5%.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's
awesome because it
sounds like it's going to
save me time and energy
and give me better security.
And if I recall,
this partnership
between Google and
Palo Alto Networks
has been pretty darn
successful, right?
MASON YAN: Yeah, that's correct.
We are very proud that Palo
Alto Networks was awarded
as the Technology Partner of
the Year for the past three
consecutive years out of
thousands of Google Cloud
technology partners.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Sounds great.
And we all love it when
everything works perfectly.
But what happens when
something actually goes wrong?
And how are you able to help me
with some of these solutions?
MASON YAN: Yeah, as
you know, no matter
how good your security solution
is, the breaches happen.
When it happens, you want to
minimize the damage, right?
So you race against the time.
That's the life at
security operations.
The tools like Cortex XDR stop
breaches because it does--
it not only has the
visibility to your endpoint,
but also to your
firewall in the network
and your Cloud asset and
security events in your Cloud.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So getting
that visibility helps me respond
and helps me minimize
the blast radius.
Can this help me against
both small hobbyist attackers
and big professional hackers?
MASON YAN: Yeah,
that's the goal, right?
So you must have heard of
APT, Advanced Persistent
Threshold, the most
sophisticated cyber criminals.
So they are equipped with
advanced attack software
techniques and create--
they're creating a
tremendous challenge
to security professionals.
So how would we know our
cybersecurity solutions
is robust enough to protect
us from APTs attack?
So industry uses MITRE
ATT&CK evaluations.
The evaluation, it really test
the user, test the solutions,
like if the solution
could detect and protect
from ATPs attacks.
So the evaluation emulate
the real-world attack
sequences APT uses.
And Cortex XDR was ranked
the highest protection
and visibility combined score
out of 29 solutions last year.
Cortex XDR blocked
100% of attack
in the protection phase
against both Linux and Windows
endpoint.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Wow,
that's fantastic.
So let's say I'm at a
company, and we want
to operate in a zero trust way.
But I also need to
understand, what's
the current state of all
these different computers
that my people have,
especially when many of them
are bringing their own devices,
they're working from home,
and I can't necessarily
reach out and touch
and check and update those?
So can you help me with that?
MASON YAN: Yeah, so
for the zero trust,
Google has been building
a very effective access
control for the Cloud
resources and the SaaS
applications, which is part of
the BeyondCore architecture.
Context-aware access level
provide a Cloud native way
to control the access.
I think one of the biggest
challenge, as you mentioned,
is to understand the security
postures of your endpoints,
right?
And you don't want a
compromised endpoint
to access your Cloud resources
and SaaS applications.
Cortex XDR deploy the security
agents to the endpoints.
The agent stops malware,
exploits, and ransomware.
Cortex XDR creates
alerts, incidents
from malicious
activities at endpoint.
Think about if we can just add
this endpoint security posture
as part of the Google
BeyondCore context
policy, context-aware policy.
So I think we can prevent
a compromised computer
from accessing core resources
and SaaS applications.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That sounds great.
So by putting some software
on my employees' machines,
you're both helping me stop
those attacks on the one hand,
and detecting malicious
activity to flag
a machine as compromised.
So what's all the magic
behind the scenes that's
giving you the information
to calculate a health
level for each device?
MASON YAN: Yeah, so
the Cortex XDR, they
include a broad set of
exploits protection module.
So it could protect you from
the malware infection, exploits.
And also, the Cortex XDR
could actually protect you
from a malicious file download.
So we pretty much
have two phases.
The first, we would just
examine the file locally
and use the machine
learning abilities
to figure out if this
file is first seen,
if it's a known file.
And if the local analysis
is not able to figure out,
we have a industrial well-known
security service sandbox
service called WildFire.
The file would get
uploaded to WildFire.
WildFire should be
able to figure out
if we detect some
new zero-day malware,
we would notify the entire
Palo Alto's install base.
So everybody get a benefit
from this analysis.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's great.
And that sounds like it's going
to keep lots of my computers
much, much safer.
So this output also plugs
into Google's security system
so that I can make good
decisions about how healthy
or how safe one individual
client device is, right?
And then that lets me decide
whether to let it in or not?
MASON YAN: Yeah, that's correct.
So for that purpose, we joined
Google BeyondCorp Alliance
program.
We develop a solution
called Cortex XDR endpoint
verification.
So the first release, we pretty
much measure three things.
So number one, we
want to make sure
the endpoint is protected
by Cortex XDR agent.
And number two, the
endpoint should not
be isolated by your
security admin.
So that means the
endpoint is compromised.
So number three, we want to make
sure there is a health score--
the health score meet
your threshold you set up.
So we calculate the threshold
in the first release
by alerts, number of alerts,
if the alerts is severe enough.
And the next release,
we're going to also include
instance information.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And those
alerts and future incidents,
those are based on phishy
activity basically, right?
MASON YAN: Yep, that's correct.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
OK, so this is going
to make me a lot more secure.
How is it going to help
me prevent some compromise
or intrusion?
MASON YAN: Yeah,
so our solution,
we automatically update
Google's employee management
with the endpoint security
posture from Cortex XDR.
Once we have that done, you can
create a context-aware access
policy.
Then you can use the
Google, for example, IAPs,
maybe the service control to
control the access to the Cloud
resources.
And also that same access level,
you can apply the access policy
to your SaaS application,
including the Workspace
and third-party applications.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So get this
agent on all my devices.
Set up some kind of
endpoint datastore.
Hook it all up to Google's
zero trust posture.
This sounds like a lot of work.
Do I have to do all of
that manually by myself?
MASON YAN: We try to make this
deployment as easy as possible.
So I think what you
would need to do
is just deploy the
Cloud function we build
and to your Cloud environment.
And the Cloud function would
just reach out to Cortex XDR.
The API and the Cortex XDR
would reach out to the endpoint,
get endpoint security
posture information.
The solution review would
automatically update the Google
endpoint management.
And from there,
the access level,
you can fix, or take
the magic and prevent
that compromised endpoint access
to Cloud resources, and also
the SaaS application.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Great.
So in the unlikely but
inevitable event that something
bad does happen,
how is this going
to also help me minimize the
damage, restrict the blast
radius?
MASON YAN: Yeah, so
if anything is happen,
so the first step, the
Cortex FDR agent would
prevent the malware,
ransomware, exploit
to damage your endpoint.
But at the same time,
the Cortex XDR agent
would create alert,
create incidents.
And those security
posture information
would get transferred into
Google endpoint management.
And the Google
context-aware access level
will prevent a
compromised endpoint
from accessing Google resource
and also the SaaS application.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Awesome.
So let's say I want to try
this out and move forward.
What should I do first?
MASON YAN: So Cortex XDR
endpoint verification
is in private preview
at this point.
Contact us at
google@paloaltonetworks.com.
We will get you started.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's awesome.
Thank you very much,
Mason, for joining,
and for telling us about some
of these really cool, innovative
security solutions.
MASON YAN: Thank you, Max.
My pleasure to talk to you.
Really appreciate you promote
the Cortex XDR endpoint
verification for BeyondCore.
Thank you.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If you
liked what you saw today
and you want to
see more like it,
you can check out the
full playlist below.
Please make sure you
like and subscribe
to get more content
from "Architecting
with Google Cloud."
[MUSIC PLAYING]